[Music]
welcome to the plate course I'm really
glad you're here you're about to go on a
journey of the mind-body connection and
personal expression
you're going to learn all the basic
movements of POI
plus skills and knowledge that will let
you master them and you're going to
learn a lot about learning I've talked
quite a thousands of people I've been
teaching professional E for 12 years so
I have a lot I can share with you and
perhaps the most important thing of all
is this the thing that's going to
determine whether this is smooth or
frustrating is whether you practice the
lead-ups straight out of old martial
arts movies right Crotty kid if you take
the time with each hand and you do the
lead ups and enjoy them and find how
they're interesting one hand and then
the other hand and polish the pieces
then putting the pieces together in the
final movement it's fun and smooth if
you jump ahead and just try to do the
you know move it you want to get to
without polishing the pieces then it can
be really frustrating
so I'll be coaching you through this
through the entire course and coming
back to the idea over and over again and
in the real word courses I do that and
there's always a few students who don't
listen so it's up to you you can be one
of the people who enjoy silly tips and
finds POI smooth and fun to learn or you
can be one of the few people who jump
ahead to the final move all the time and
find quite frustrating I'm not attached
that's your choice but of course I
prefer if you have fun so practice the
lead-ups we have 150 videos awaiting
you've got a whole community of people
playing with you
hopefully it sounds from friends in the
real world so let's get started
[Music]